thank you
the Security Council is called to order
in the security Council chamber
Ukraine's foreign minister wanted to
remember the cost of the past year the
cost of Russia's invasion
I kindly ask everyone
to observe a minute of Silence
in memory of the victims of the
aggression but Russia's representative
here interrupted the silence he had
another idea
and that is why we're rising to honor
the memory of them all
the Russian version of history is that
Ukraine started all this the minute
silence resumed he had successfully
seized the moment
they were in this chamber a year ago
exactly when Vladimir Putin in Moscow
chose to announce his move on Ukraine it
represented a total rejection of this
chamber this institution and the global
order it tries to preserve
and this anniversary was a chance to
count the cost
Putin cannot must not win in Ukraine
because what's at stake on the
battlefields
is the international order itself
and that is at the heart
of the United Nations
if Russia stops fighting and leaves
Ukraine the war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting Ukraine ends
the fact remains
one man
Vladimir Putin started this war
one man can end it
there is such symbolism to this place
the highest diplomatic body in the world
moments in here have changed history and
yet right now it does feel powerless
never mind the overwhelming rejection of
Russia and its actions in Thursday's
vote here Russia has a seat and the
power to block any initiatives that are
proposed the Chinese did present one a
12-point plan hardly a road map to peace
but an indication that they haven't
moved even closer to Russia first of all
I would like to thank you in your
Nations as the Western Alliance foreign
ministers spoke their leaders gathered
for a meeting of the G7 the outcome
bluntly was more words but nothing to
unlock a negotiation the message the
fighting cannot stop until Russia
withdraws
back in New York the shuttle diplomacy
for what it's worth continues in truth
though this day could only be about
reflex section of a year that changed
the world because there is no projection
for what comes next we never give up we
are ukrainians thank you